Avengers: Endgame tugged on our heartstrings
plenty but a deleted scene would have straight-up
yanked on them.
The scene in question, recently made available
on Disney+, depicts Tony Stark visiting an
ethereal afterlife immediately after his universe-saving
snap.
There, he encounters an adult version of his
daughter Morgan.
While Endgame directors Joe and Anthony Russo
had previously discussed the scene, we had
yet to get a look at it before now and it's
every bit as poignant as you'd expect.
In the scene, Stark suddenly finds himself
alone in the peaceful realm, seemingly confused
as to where everybody went.
Just as he begins to realize what must be
happening, Morgan makes her appearance.
At first, Stark isn't sure who he's looking
at but when Morgan offers the clue that the
two are "pretty close," he figures it out
pretty quickly.
Stark's face registers a thousand emotions
as he looks at the daughter he'll never get
to know, and he admits to wondering if he
made the wrong decision in sacrificing himself.
And, of course, the scene ends exactly as
you'd expect:
"I love you 3000."
There's amazing chemistry in the scene between
Robert Downey Jr. and Katherine Langford,
who unfortunately was robbed of an appearance
in the biggest movie of all time when this
scene hit the cutting room floor.
It wouldn't surprise us, though, if Morgan
Stark were to make an appearance in a future
MCU film, or several.
In their commentary on the scene, the Russo
brothers explained that it was conceived as
a sort of bookend to a scene in Avengers:
Infinity War.
Specifically, the scene in which Thanos, having
just accomplished his mission to snap half
of all life in the universe out of existence,
was basically transported inside the Soul
Stone.
There, he encountered a young version of his
adopted daughter Gamora, who was one of the
many people who died at Thanos' hands so that
he could accomplish his mission.
Joe Russo explained:
"We sent him to what we would call the 'Waystation,'
to mirror what had happened to Thanos."
Anthony Russo added that:
"The idea is that this moment... that act
[of using the Infinity Stones] sort of forces
you to confront, or reconcile, something that's
unresolved in yourself, in your soul."
Joe then explained that the reason an adult
Morgan was cast was so Stark could come to
terms with what he had done, and truly understand
the fact that he was giving up so much time
spent with his daughter throughout her life.
However, at the end of the day, the scene
was cut for reasons that are pretty understandable
when you're talking about a flick that already
ran in excess of three hours: pacing.
As Joe Russo put it:
"When we put this in the film, we felt like
it ground the movie to a halt.
And [Stark] does something similar in the
next sequence, when he gives his own eulogy
[via hologram at his funeral]."
The director continued to say that he and
his brother were mindful of adding too many
endings, which is a problem that popped up
in The Lord of the Rings: The Return of the
King.
Audiences might have felt like the film had
ended on the perfect sentimental note, only
for it to continue on to another, and another.
According to Joe:
"What can happen at the end of a film this
big is you can have ending after ending after
ending, and it starts to feel like the movie's
never gonna end."
In other words, the power of the individual
moments are watered-down:
"When you have too many sequences in a row,
you can dilute the value of each one of them."
Taking all of these things into account, the
pair reluctantly decided that the scene had
to go.
Still, that doesn't mean we can't admire its
power.
Anyone in their right mind would admit that
there wouldn't have been a dry eye in the
house at its conclusion had they left it in.
Unfortunately, only time will tell whether
Morgan Stark will make any further appearances
in the MCU.
In the meantime, though, you can revisit the
triumphs and tragedies of Avengers: Endgame
to your heart's content with a Disney+ subscription.
The movie is available to watch on the new
streaming service right now.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.